non c'est vrai elle a raison ça
s'appelle le veut pas dire non mais vous
savez qu'on fait l'émission l'a donc oui
alors non mais c'est vrai on savait
malade y pensait avoir à les payer et ce
métier non mais aussi les pays et
d'acteurs saisie du mois mais constante
et pourrait voir son sexe papa c'est un
film érotique
sinon c'est normal un au milieu de la
loge comme ça ils sont pas au mieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les 105 nadège et nouvelles votre quête
sur un jeune arrive et pas le faire avec
le doigt et que j'ai beaucoup plus
pratique rc de plus en plus de gens le
fou et j'ai eu otis ils ont de plus en
plus de problèmes avec ça
reportage dans cet avis sur sa dague et
raison particulière de 8 si vous avez
fait quoi
merci jean luc rader on va passer au
tour de magie du jour là sa part
complètement kaka matin